[Musique]
le 19 ou 1969 un nom familier dans les
cercles du base-ball se joignait aux
expos claude raymond cinquante ans déjà
monsieur raymond on va vous avez signé
un livre d'or jour du monde et les
années passent
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que ça
correspond tétard renouveau des expos
bientôt mais assez c'est vraiment une
fête le cinquantenaire je brûle la peau
passé mais tout à coup les gens se sont
mis à parler de ça c'est une belle
occasion de fêter ce 50e il ya parce que
quand ça a commencé à 69 ont passé que
ça pour gérer simple 150,1 parce que les
villes le baseball c'était pour la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
saisie d'un territoire des balles en jeu
là
match est terminé il s'est en effet
rangé pour l'histoire derniers matchs
les disques ans
expo 1
vous étiez même là la cérémonie de
fermeture votre vie mais c'est vous qui
avez lancé symboliquement le dernier
lancer vous souvenez très bien je me
souviens très bien
c'est une journée il a joint les plus
tristes de ma vie
l'abaissement disparaissait de montréal
puis je me suis dit lâche vz sur le
terrain je suis le dernier à être sur le
terrain choisi sur modules que j'ai dit
'tiens retrouver de bail pourra faire le
dernier lassé de l'histoire des expos de
montréal
je les fais mais avant ça j'avais fait
un disque ou de j'avais fini indien
avant merci beaucoup plus que j'avais
fait pour moi et l'équipe
pendant ces 30 cette année
j'espère que un jour nora berra
ça viendra ici alors peut-être que le
maroc janvier servi aux régions sont
prévues monsieur brown semaine tu la
gagnes là qui veulent leur faire revenir
les képis
tout le monde est optimiste on croit que
l'équipe de tampa ça va fonctionner vous
ce que vous y croyez ou dit attendons le
voir je peux me réjouir trouvé ben moi
j'ai toujours été un petit peu comme sa
taxe est pas fini c'est pas j'y crois
pas aux valeurs là je commence à y
croire parce que écoutez je regarde ce
qui se passe à tampa à tampa la ville
veut pas construire un stade puis là ça
prend absolument instable c'est le
propriétaire il se fâche medibelge
je pars vers montréal avec mon équipe il
peut rien faire racontez-moi votre match
avec les braves
vous êtes à montréal vous n'êtes pas
avec les expos aux attaques les braves
vous souvenez vous de ça comme stagiaire
vous est ce qu'on regarde
ces moments-là constat hier oui c'est
comme il ya puis je suis à près du corps
et aussi en même temps c'était le 16 mai
1969 j'étais avec les brèves puis
camille québécois a joué dans un match
au québec league baseball majeur quand
je suis arrivé au mois du culte claude
mouton qui était le maître de céans
l'annonceur maison
il est maintenant de saint-jean à québec
le numéro 36 yam un portail d'annoncés
mots non dans le monde s'est levé d'un
bloc puis tout le monde n'a pu que je
n'avais jamais eu une ovation comme ça
avant ça émouvant
puis moi je jamais été le genre de gars
qui laissait voir ses émotions
croyez-moi ou projet la balle va
échapper des doigts là il ya une coupe
de l'âme qui ont coulé un petit peu non
mes deux meilleurs james frain coda est
vaste et lumineux le sava le premier but
sont des voyous du frenchie alors au tac
je dis que tu veux jouer à montréal
boc toile derrière pire sur les fronts
de gagner en 11e manche sur le circuit
de tito franco des innovations déjà
encore après le match rénovation je
n'avais jamais vu ça de ma vie
exceptionnelle bon après aussi vous avez
joué avec les expos quelques années de
ces années là les belles années que vous
retenez quoi et qu'est ce que ça donne à
une ville comme montréal d'avoir un club
comme cela vous est mersin de renommée
internationale à tous les jours on
parlait de montréal au japon à cuba
porto rico aux états unis à travers le
monde
puis vous des tout jeunes le baseball a
fait partie de la vie de quartiers
visités ce boulevard gouin le baseball
d'un parcours baseball à cette époque là
est ce que vous pensez que ça peut
revenir ce que le baseball pour les
petits gars pour les petit film devienne
le sport qu'on aime qu'on aime à les
voir nous quand on était jeune il
fallait presque se battre pour avoir
intérêt de balle puis les premiers
arrivés sont les premiers servis on a
refusé nos équipes on tirait avec le
bâton puis on s'amusait aujourd'hui je
regrette d'avoir beaucoup de terrains
qui sont inoccupés durant
durant l'été c'est sûr que si les
experts viennent va y avoir un regain de
vie parce que même à l'heure actuelle
dans le baseball québec qui ont une
augmentation à chaque année de
description moi ce que je regrette le
plus c'est que les gants à part une
paire ou la mère ou la grammaire ils
peuvent pas mener leurs petits-enfants
moi j'ai quatre enfants il n'a juste un
sur les quatre qui est venue du baseball
majeur
là pendant la série 6 contre toronto
ils vont pouvoir mener mes trois os
qu'est ce que ça vous a amené dans le
baseball c'est votre vie c'est ma vie
voiture je dois tout besbas quand
j'étais petite je rêvais de jouer junior
à ce jeu avait joué dans la ligue
provinciale tout à coup ça s'est bien
éclaté j'ai signé leur gré de jouer
tranquillement le second au baseball
majeur
le baseball majeur a fait voyager à
travers la bande la baisse bug majeur
tout donner ce que je vous ai vu alors
on verra ça va revenir se voir renaître
à montréal
espérance et les doigts vont vraiment un
plaisir nous avons un compte moi aussi
fade nausée
[Musique]